yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
Zootopia is finally coming out on
blu-ray and DVD so I wanted to take a
look at some of the characters who were
deleted from the final customer movie
I'm gonna break down who they were and
how they would have fits into the story
just be a word that if you haven't seen
the film yet there will be a few
spoilers so if that bothers you check
out my spoiler free review here honey
badger was a female friend of Nicks who
believed in the conspiracy theory that
sheep was secretly running the world
hany lived in a bunker that was fitted
out with some hilarious anti sheep
weaponry ranging from shearing scissors
to a hedge trimmer and from waxing
strips to a golf bag filled with
fireworks in real life honey badgers of
very fierce animals and honey's
character was designed to appear
unstable she had different sized eyes
and went around with stained clothes and
food in her hair some early concept art
shows some of the funny conspiracy
theories that honey believed about sheep
and given this in the end we find out
that bellwethers actually the villain
Phoebe honey did have a point after all
Penny's character wasn't completely lost
to the movie though as she turns up as
dr. Maj honey badger the doctor doing
research from allied heart on the
imprisoned predators at cliffside asylum
the javel jerks are a pair of annoying
troublesome little rodentia he used to
aggravate Nick by deliberately running
over his tail and their little red car
and every time they did that Nick would
get a shock from his tame collar which
predators had to work in early drafts of
Zootopia the tame collars were designed
to keep predators under control and I'll
talk more about them in my video on
zootopia's deleted scenes and rejected
concepts which you can click right here
to watch cause love the polar bear who
carries mr. big into the room where Nick
and Judy awating has a five-year-old son
called Morris Morris actually appears in
a deleted scene called the taming party
which is a rite of passage ceremony in
which young predators receive tame
colors the scene features an emotional
and tender moment when Kozlov gives his
son Morris his tame collar
which signifies his son's acceptance
into Zootopia society as he celebrates
at the party Morris gets shocked by the
caller actually Cory Loftus the movie's
character art director has said that
Morris is the deleted character he
misses the most Morris's look
deliberately designed to make him appear
innocent in comparison to his gangster
polar-bear father Kozlov Dougs around
started out life as a character called
Willy who also worked for bellwether but
at her office rather than in their
Breaking Bad star lab Willy was also a
villain who managed to disguise the fact
that he was shredding paper work by
looking like he was eating paper out of
cans also using a corset and overcoat
woody would disguise himself as a wolf
making him a clever twist on the phrase
a wolf in sheep's clothing by the way at
the end of the final version of the
movie that phrase actually does come to
life when BOGO tells the wolf police
officer Wofford to put on a Rams mask to
go undercover
the Razorbacks were an elite tactical
police team that would be deployed in
the event of predators getting out of
control they were named Razorbacks after
the North American term for wild boar or
hog and just like wild boar the
Razorbacks had the ability to sniff out
predators and so sometimes were also
referred to as sniffers during
zootopia's development the team had lots
of different ideas for a goat character
eventually these culminated in a
character called Mabel the old goat who
is created as a meter maid partner for
Judy the scene that was storyboarded but
didn't make the cut was rather amusing
and featured Mabel telling Judy to keep
up the good work as in 50 years time she
could look forward to being promoted to
Mabel's position originally bellwether
wasn't going to be the movies villain
instead directors Byron Howard and rich
Moore planned to have a pig as a films
baddie the reason for this initial
choice was that pigs are said to be very
smart animals this villainous pig was
going to be called mur Swinton and she
was designed to be both extremely clever
and smartly dressed so guys what do you
think about the deleted characters and
would you like to seen any of them in
the movie and who's your favorite
character in Zootopia let me know in the
comments below just to let you know
coming up I'll have a cool giveaway for
this awesome the artists who drop a list
hardback book on my neck Zootopia video
so make sure you subscribe to see that
in the meantime you can check out my
Zootopia playlist below including my 25
things you didn't know about Sue topia
my full Easter egg guide to the movie
and
five favorite moments from the film
thanks for watching and see you next
time you be gay a movie lovers